Catastrophe from him I hope now on the
normal game oh god oh god that was
terrible that's what it's called well well
somehow it comes from France
so ended up with the spoon B5 seats
so the only variant here from a
black perspective that I've at least
seen once but I know it  I don't
actually make the move, just H3,
yes, he obviously thinks
that's not a problem if he
gets the pawn position, I have
no idea,
so
you would have to go to the black
squares, yes, that would be consistent, but
G6 or E5 again G6 first
the five  Knight E5
should actually be okay,
so you need a little bit of caution here with black to get
up here and so
in that sense, a little bit of caution is called for.
E5 yes, okay, do it like that, but
it's not
somehow
clearly bad for white or something like that
yes F45 yes, I didn't see it like that,
phew,
wow, yes my first impulse was G6 was
actually E5 and often the first
idea is the first idea is also the
right idea,
well, knight G4
comes to E5 and probably passes by
or then somehow goes to Queen B6  so
completely sick
is really sick no actually ca
n't walk at all
I'll get
to 6 then there
's also four chess and so
no that's never going to work in my life well let's
see if he were to get F2 thick now he
would probably have to or
or give it  the chess I have to
make the brilliant move either
knight D7
or king the eight king the 8 is
incredibly sick to
do
that doesn't work at all what I wanted to do
on tom E2
I actually wanted to do knight E4
then it works  A4
okay but good okay if he plays two for me
then I would also have the
strange breeding jumper A5
I could beat you now I can
beat you here
that won't be so bad anymore
or hopefully
well good okay I have to take it
so
P2 depends  also
or simply knight H5
well then he has the chess again here
no it's also [ __ ]
knight he has the seven knight E6
well I also have the completely
crazy move queen simply B2
but that's the one that's really
crazy I think
I have it  not so much time
always has to move
yes E6 maybe
no idea then runner G7
maybe that's still
possible but of course everything seems more than risky
so if you now have a two move
high one somehow then it's possible but
ask now if I experience the moves here
since A4 yes then I probably have to do something
like
Bishop G7 now
in the hope that we can get out of here again,
yes that's what I actually thought King F8 like that
and now F5
but
not being able to see directly what should happen now
I also think there is a threat of Bishop D4
if  he sacrifices something F5 or
something like that, it doesn't
matter
so that's now somewhat
secured so
now I have to get a king
to H7
so I
made up a bit of time
so the little trick
actually wins now,
yes whether the opening is
done correctly there  I have my
doubts
where it was probably really flat
somehow but well it was definitely interesting